welcome back in the last video I showed
you or hopefully I did show you that if
I apply a force of F to a stationary an
initially stationary object with mass m
and I apply that force for a distance D
that that force times distance the force
times the distance that I'm pushing the
object is equal to one-half MV squared
where m is the mass of the object and V
is the velocity object after pushing it
for a distance of D and we defined in
that last video we just said that this
is work force times distance by
definition is work and one-half MV
squared I said this is called kinetic
energy kinetic energy and so by
definition kinetic energy is the amount
of work and I mean this is the
definition right here it's the amount of
work you need to put into an object or
apply to an object to get it from rest
to its current velocity so it's velocity
over here so let's just say I looked at
an object here with mass m and it was
moving with the velocity V I would say
well this has this has a kinetic energy
of one-half MV squared and if the
numbers are confusing you let's say the
mass was I don't know let's say this was
a five kilogram object and it's moving
at seven meters per second so I would
say the kinetic energy of this object is
going to be five one-half times the mass
times 5 times 7 squared times velocity
squared times 49 so let's see one-half
times 49 that's a little under 25 so
it'll be approximately 125 Newton meters
which is approximately a Newton meter is
just a Joule 125 joules so this is f we
actually put numbers in and so when we
immediately know this even if we didn't
know what happened how did this object
get to this B let's say we didn't know
that you know someone else had applied a
force of M for
a a distance of D to this object just by
calculating its kinetic energy as 125
joules we immediately know that that's
the amount of work that was necessary
and we don't know if this is exactly how
this object got to this velocity but we
know that that is the amount of work
that was necessary to accelerate the
object to this velocity of seven meters
per second so let's give another example
and in this instead of this time just
pushing something in a horizontal
direction and accelerating it I'm just
an example we're gonna push something up
but it's it's velocity really isn't
gonna change invert let's say I have a
different situation and we're on this
planet we're not in deep space and I
have a mass of M and I were to apply a
force so let's say the force that I
apply is equal to mass times the
acceleration of gravity mass times let's
just call that gravity right 9.8 meters
per second squared and I would apply
this force for a distance of D upwards
right or the stead of D let's say H H
for height right so in this case the
force times the distance is equal to
well the force is mass times the
acceleration of gravity right and
remember I'm pushing with the
acceleration of gravity upwards while
the exact acceleration of gravity is
pulling downwards so let's say so the
force is mass times gravity and I'm
applying that for a distance of H right
D is H so the force is this this is the
force and then the distance I'm applying
is going to be H and what's interesting
is and this is a bit of less I mean if
you want to think of an exact situation
imagine an an elevator that is already
moving because you would actually have
to apply a force slightly larger than
the acceleration of gravity just to get
the object moving but let's say that the
object is already a constant velocity
let's say it's an elevator and it is
just going up with a constant velocity
and let's say the mass of the elevator
is that
10 kilograms 10 kilograms and it moves
up with a constant velocity it moves up
I don't know it moves up 100 meters so
we know that the work done by whatever
was pulling on this elevator probably
was the tension in this wire that was
pulling up on the elevator but we know
that the work done is the force
necessary to pull up on it well that's
just going to be the force of gravity so
we're assuming that the elevator is not
accelerating right because if the
accelerator was accelerating upwards
than the force applied to it would be
more than the force of gravity and if
the Excel if the elevator was
accelerating downwards or if it was
slowing down upwards then the force
being applied would be less than the
acceleration of gravity but since the
elevator is at a constant velocity
moving up we know that the force pulling
upwards is completely equal to the force
pulling downwards right no net force
because gravity and this force are at
the same level so there's no change in
velocity I think I said that two times
so we know that this upward force is
equal to the force of gravity so this is
at least in magnitude in the opposite
direction so this is this is mg so
what's M M is 10 kilograms times the
acceleration of gravity let's say that's
9.8 meters per second squared
I'm not writing the unit's here but
we're all assuming you know kilograms
and meters per second squared and we're
moving that for a distance of 100 meters
100 meters so how much work was put into
this elevator I get or into this object
it doesn't have to be an elevator
by whatever force that was essentially
pushing up on it or pulling up on it and
so let's see this would be 98 times 100
so it's 9800 Newton meters or 9800
joules and when we're at the top of when
we after we've moved up 100 meters
notice there's no change in velocity so
so the question is where did all that
that work get put into the object and
and the answer here is is that the work
got transferred to something called
potential energy so and potential energy
is defined as well gravitational
potential energy will work with other
types of potential energy later with
and things potential energy is defined
as mass times the force of gravity times
the height that the object is at and why
is this called potential energy because
at this point the energy work had to be
put into the object to get it to this in
the case of gravitational potential
energy work had to be put into the
object to get it to this height but the
object now it's not moving or anything
so it doesn't have any kinetic energy
but it now has a lot of potential to do
work and what do I mean that what do I
mean by potential to do work well after
I move an object up 100 meters into the
air what's its potential to do work well
I could just let go of it and and and
have no no outside force other than
gravity the gravity will still be there
and because of gravity the object will
come down and be in a very very fast
velocity when it lands and you know
maybe I could apply this to some machine
or something and this thing could do
work and and if that's a little
confusing let me give you an example it
all works together with our so let's say
I have an object that is oh I don't know
a 1 kilogram object and we're on earth
and let's say that it is 10 meters above
the ground
10 meters above the ground so we know
that it's potential energy potential
energy is equal to mass times
gravitational acceleration times height
so mass is 1 gravitational acceleration
let's just say gravitational
acceleration is 10 meters per second
squared times 10 meters per second
squared times 10 meters which is the
height so it's approximately equal to
100 Newton meters which is the same
thing as 100 joules fair enough and what
did we know about this we know that it
would take about a hundred ignore
exactly 100 joules of work to get this
object from the ground to this point up
here now what we can do now is use our
traditional kinematics formulas to
figure out well if I just let this
object go how fast will it be when it
hits the ground
and we could do that but what I'll show
you is even a faster way and this is
where all of the work and energy really
becomes useful we have something called
the law of conservation of energy is
that energy cannot be created or
destroyed it just gets transferred from
one form to another and there is some
minor caveats to that for but for our
purposes we'll just stick with that so
in this situation where I just take the
object and I let go up here up here it
has a ton of potential energy right and
what by the time it's down here it has
no potential energy because the height
becomes zero right what's its potential
inner so here potential energy is equal
to 100 and here potential energy is
equal to zero and so the natural
question is I just told you the law of
conservation of energy but if you look
at this example all the potential energy
just disappeared and it looks like I'm
running out of time but what I'll show
you in the next video is that that
potential energy gets converted into
another type of energy and I think you
might be able to guess what type that is
because this object is going to be
moving really fast right before it hits
the ground I'll see in the next video